Miriam: I am a child survivor from Poland.
Poland was home to the largest Jewish population
in Europe.
By inviting a Holocaust survivor, you remember
the murder of Jews of Europe.
You keep their memory alive.
Ayla: Miriam’s story to me is very touching.
You know, being Jewish, I have family who
were lost in the Holocaust, and we have no
records whatsoever, in many cases not even
a name, and it’s very touching to see Miriam’s
story and how she brought her memories together.
Abby: It’s inspiring, it’s heartwarming,
it’s moving.
I think it’s brilliant that she was able
to write this story out and go through all
of that again, relive it.
Abby: So Miriam, your book is all about, you
know, rediscovering your memory and then sharing
those memories in your story, and I was wondering
what specifically motivated you to rediscover
your Jewish heritage?
Miriam: I don’t even think that we can speak
about “rediscovering,” because I was eight,
over eight.
I was born June 2nd, I left home in ’41
in November, so it’s eight and three months.
I knew who I was.
I was hiding, actively hiding.
So when I returned to who I was, it was a
very slow, fearful process.
I was really afraid.
Ayla: So in Trains, you wrote a lot about
the nature of perspective, and how you remember
differently now that you’re older.
As you were writing Trains, how did your perspective
on your story change.
Miriam: The story is the same, but I allowed
myself, as I went along with the book, I allowed
myself to admit to feelings, to admit to hurt.
I think it helped me become a truer person.
When I decided to tell my story, and that
was after the first gathering of child survivors,
and I stood up, was out waiting for my turn
to run through the middle of the room, and
started talking, just words poured out of
me, and I think some recollection of things
that were there, but I did not recall them
really, did not acknowledge them – like
my grandfather praying, he was a Hassidic
Jew – and I was speaking about that.
And when I sat down, also by the reaction
of people, the survivors, it was a gathering
of the survivors, I realized that I need to
write.
So when I started writing, I looked at a photograph
of me, the young Winter at her first communion,
that’s the only thing I had, nothing physical
except for that photograph.
And it really went like a spiral, deeper and
deeper, when I allowed myself to not rush,
but also to stop in the middle of a sentence,
or pick up from nowhere and just start writing.
Ben: There’s a part of your book where you
say, “I am their witness,” and the theme
of witnessing comes up a lot in your book.
What is your goal as a witness?
Miriam: To tell what I know happened.
My field is theater, but my hobby through
all my life was history, and I do know history.
But I do not, when I speak about the Holocaust,
I speak only about the things that I know,
and that’s important for me because I want
to tell what had happened from that perspective,
from what as a child, during the Holocaust,
in Poland, what I witnessed – not what I
heard, what I witnessed of what had happened.
Ayla: So what do you hope that students especially
will learn as they read your story?
Miriam: The story must be told, and the memory
of what happened must be kept alive.
That was, that is now, a very strong motivation
for many other Jewish child survivors, not
only for me.
It definitely is for me, and I think it was
so from the very beginning: to tell what happened